savez-vous qu'une étude menée par
l'université une feuille qui démontrent
qu'après seulement 150 clic j'aime sur
facebook mais l'intelligence
artificielle arrive à dresser un profil
de vous qui est plus précis que ce que
peut faire un membre de votre propre
famille tout ça pour dire que tout ce
qu'on fait sur facebook laisse des
traces et en dit très long sur nous mais
peut-on se protéger ou au moins limiter
la diffusion de nos informations
personnelles première chose on peut
d'abord limitée qui peut nous voir sur
facebook pour ça il faut cliquer sur le
petit triangle qui situé en haut à
droite de l'écran et choisir paramètres
ensuite aller complètement à gauche et
sélectionnez confidentialité c'est là
que vous allez décider qui peut voir vos
futures publications vous allez pouvoir
examiner les publications dans
lesquelles vous apparaissez est aussi
limité l'accès à vos vieilles
publication si dans le passé vous avez
publié des bêtises c'est peut-être une
bonne chose à faire
c'est également dans cet anglais qu'on
peut déterminer qui peut retrouver notre
profil et qui peut voir la liste de nos
amis vos amis facebook
ils ont accès à vos informations mais
quand vos amis facebook s'inscrivent à
des applications wade jeu en utilisant
facebook
aidez vos amis ils rendent vos
informations disponibles pour limiter
l'accès à ces informations personnelles
il faut être plus cliquez sur le petit
triangle en haut à droite et choisir
paramètres à gauge l'écrin cliquez sur
application ensuite il faut appuyer sur
modifier dans la section intitulée
applications que d'autres utilisent en
désactivant chaque cas vous empêcher vos
amis de rendre aux informations
personnelles disponibles mais ce qu'il
faut peut-être retenir de tout ça c'est
que si vous souhaiter à tout prix
protéger vos données personnelles
eh bien il faut peut-être ne pas aller
sur facebook parce que même si vous
désactivez votre compte
tout ce que vous avez fait jusque là
vaut rester